- Hey, so hello and welcome
everyone to re:Invent 2025.
Thanks for being here,
especially considering
this is a 9:00 AM session.
I hope jet lag is treating you all well.
We are here today to talk about incident
and it's a really good thing
that we haven't had one in a while, right?
So let's start off off
with a bit of background on
who we are and why we are here today.
I'm muted, okay?
I'm Giorgio, I'm a principal
in AWS Enterprise support,
that is the organization
that supports our customers in
their day-to-day improvement
of operations and resilience.
- And I'm Anthony.
I'm a principal engineer in
the AWS event management team.
We're part of the AWS Health organization.
- And together we have more than 20 years
of combined experience in
all things incident at AWS,
from detection to resolution
and implementation of action items,
and we are here today to share
some lessons we have learned
over time, tips and tricks,
and discuss how we do
things here at Amazon.
- Okay, so with a show of hands,
how many folks here have
been involved either
in an incident or after an incident?
Okay, looks like most of us,
well, you're in the right spot.
So today we're gonna go through
a couple different things.
We're gonna talk about event
management at AWS, specifically
how we do it, how we
detect, how we engage,
and then we're gonna focus the discussion
around the retrospective phase, which is
where we'll focus on specifically
how we do that at scale,
and we'll start with how we
trigger and manage events
and then zoom into that.
But I want to key in on the fact
that the post incident
is not just the creation
of a document, right?
It's really deep diving
and truly understanding the root cause.
And so we'll talk about the five why's
and a couple different
ways to get to that.
And then to wrap up, we'll
talk about specifically how
to scale it across a
very large organization.
Okay, so we're gonna start with detection.
So all events start with detection
and they end at least in the
short term with mitigation.
So for detection, we have two
broad categories of events.
The first is service-driven.
And service-driven metrics
include things like
alarms on the service, right,
so EC2 launch instances,
launch latency, et cetera.
But we also have metrics and
alarms on the subsystem layer.
And so those might
include other subsystems
in the path for the co-plan
or in the data plan in the
creation of the instances.
But we also supplement that
with synthetic monitoring,
we call them canaries,
and these are intended
to emulate the customer
experience end to end.
And so you can think of
launching an EC2 instance,
certainly we're monitoring
whether the launch was
successful, but we also want
to know whether that
instance is available,
whether it can be contacted
and responding to DNS requests.
And so those are the two
main categories of metrics
and how we detect issues.
But the third one is maybe
a little bit unique to AWS
and these are what we
call aggregate alarms.
And so these are alarms that
trigger when multiple services
are in an alarm at the same
time or multiple metrics.
Those are a little bit different
in that they engage a
full incident response
and we'll talk about that
here in just a second.
- And the second category
of metrics that we use
for detection are what
we call customer-driven.
So those are of two types.
The first one is we monitor
for traffic anomalies.
We have models that allow
us to predict the amount
of traffic that should
be hitting a service
as ascertain time of the
day in a certain region,
and if the traffic is not there,
then we trigger alarms
that start investigations
on why the traffic
cannot reach the service
and related, we track
impact report customers.
So this goes from noise on social media,
to reports on social media
to support cases raised by customers
and we analyze those trends.
And if there is an uptick on
cases about a specific service,
then it might be a sign
that we need to engage
and start investigating a potential issue
that the first category
of metrics is not good.
- Okay, so let's talk about
detection a little bit.
So I wanna show you the AWS dashboard.
And so this dashboard
legend has, it was built
in 2008, 2009 time by
an engineer from Dublin
who was visiting Seattle
and had identified the
problem that as we scale,
we needed a centralized view
into the health of AWS services
and AWS regions.
They also wanted to be able to deep dive
by partition as well.
And so what we have here is
we have a view of all of that
and we can drill into each
service and each region.
And each service onboards three
to five key performance
metrics that indicate
their services overall health,
and ultimately over the years
we've continued to develop
and own the same tool
and not much has changed,
but the goal remains the same, right?
We need that centralized
view into AWS' (indistinct).
So after detection we have engagement.
And so engagement, we have two categories
of events here as well.
We have single service events
that are triggered by service alarms.
We'll start with that.
These are alarms that engage
these, the service team
and generally only the service
team for what's in alarm.
They can engage others as required
and ultimately they can engage AWS support
and AWS support is in the loop
if customers are impacted by an issue.
Secondarily, we have multi-service events.
And so these are the
ones that are triggered
by the aggregate alarms that
I was mentioning before.
And so these ones are engagement at scale,
and so they trigger engagements
of a couple different teams.
So the first one is AWS Incident Response,
or as we call AIR.
Additionally, AWS support is involved
and engaged at the onset of the event,
all impacted services from
the creation of the event,
all the way down to the
full lifecycle of the event.
So not just what's an
alarm with the creation,
but throughout the entire time.
And at the onset of these, we also engage
what we like to call the usual suspects.
And so these will be,
you know, foundational
or core services that are low in the stack
that are often a root cause
of multi-service events.
So these are things like authentication,
DNS, networking, et cetera.
So we'll engage Route 53,
IM and our networking teams.
- So after engagements we
have the coordination phase.
And you can imagine
coordinating incident response
at AWS scale is quite a challenge.
We do this by breaking
down into work streams,
each one coordinated by a related call.
The first one is the tech call.
It involves engineers and
leaders of the affected services
and it's focused on delivering
the fastest possible mitigation a
and their solution for customers.
- And then secondarily,
we have the support call,
and the support call
focuses on communicating
with impacted customers, but
also giving customers advice
and how to recover faster.
There's oftentimes scenarios
where we can provide information
to get you outta pain earlier.
The participants on that
call include support
and service leadership.
- So the way we think about
the tech call is that we want
to run a large scale
parallel investigation
instead of serial.
So the way we'll do this
is we will engage all
of the impacted teams
and ask them to review their
services, their metrics,
and come up with impact statements.
This might be slightly different
from what you are generally used to see.
That is a sequential investigation
where each possible root
cause is removed in order.
So let's dive a bit
deeper into the tech call.
So Anthony mentioned it's supported
by a team called AWS Incident
Response, AWS AIR for France.
This is not the classic operation team.
They are not just here
to operate the cause
and coordinate the incident response,
they own the process end to end.
They own the mental models,
they own the foundations
of our incident response
and they own all of the related tooling.
So they are quite active in the process,
they're not here just for coordination.
As we say, this call
is focused on one thing
that is mitigation and
after mitigation resolution.
Large events are supported by
what we call a call leader.
Now the industry standard term
for call leaders is probably
something like incident commander.
And this is the person,
extremely senior person
that is in the call and takes decisions
where we face scenarios that
we have not experienced before.
It's a really small number of individuals,
it's single digit across the entire of AWS
and they are here to break ties
or just to take those
split second decisions
that help with incident integration.
The call is paired to a ticket,
and we have quite a strong mindset about
what is discussed in the call.
Imagine this call we often run
in the hundreds of attendees.
So having a mindset, a clear
definition of what needs
to be said in the call
and what can be written
in the ticket instead
and what must be written in the ticket
because we want to study it
for long term is really key.
And we support this to a stronger ticket.
So it's quite clear on who's
supposed to talk, it's clear
who has the microphone at
any certain point in time.
I wish we were a bit
better with muting people
because it's not an (indistinct)
to have dogs barking in the background,
helicopters taking off or similar.
And this call is the one
and main coordination
bridge for the design.
But when a service team needs some time
to maybe look deeper into
their functionalities
and involve different
engineers, they're gonna follow
to a separate one and still
keep at least one engineer
that has a bridge between the two.
So the tech call remains the
core of incident response
that can be worked out as appropriate
and as required from time to time.
So I mentioned the tech
tickets that we use
for long term storage of observation.
I want to share with
you a couple of examples
of those observation that
might make this more tangible.
So in the first example, we have a cat
or an engineer passing an error log.
Now you might think
this is quite redundant
since the error log is
stored somewhere else
and it's got a timestamp already,
but putting it here makes
it immediately visible
to the hundred software
solvers that are involved
and also gives us an indirect
piece of information.
We are gonna know later
in the post-mortem review
that at this point in time,
we were aware of this error, right?
The fact that it was
written in a log somewhere
is not the entire story,
we want to remember that at
this time we were looking at
this service, we were looking
at this other condition.
Then we have another
engineer that is reporting,
having started a rollback.
Now our pipeline tooling
obviously track time stamped
and start of rollback, but
again, it's shared here
for immediate visibility to everyone.
And the other thing that they
are doing, they share the link
to the pipeline for reviewing
the deployment status.
Again, this is one of those measures
that help keeping the
traffic on the tech call low
because you will not hear anyone asking
about the deployment status,
there are back status, they're
just gonna click on that link
and see for themselves.
Here is a case where we share metrics
and here we see the engineer
reporting 100% recovery
on their fleet.
And they do this by sharing a matrix
that shows the steady state,
shows when the anomaly started,
shows when the anomaly crossed
the alarming threshold,
and then the back to normal.
And again, this is all data
that is gonna be stored somewhere else,
but we put it here for easier reference,
especially in the post event review phase.
And finally, another,
I'd say quite common type
of observation, here we have an engineer
that is just looking around
while trying to figure out a root cause
and spots a potential
correlation with the metric.
Now this might be a red erroring,
but sharing it here for everyone
to see might have just
triggering someone else
into looking at their
service and figuring out that
that correlation was
effective, relevant and related
to the root cause of the land.
- Okay, let's take a
look at the support call.
And so the support call
owns customer communication.
It is run by AWS event management,
most frequently, the ones
that are communicating to
you for operational issues
that you see on the
personal health dashboard
and the service health dashboard.
Additionally, we proactively engage
with account teams, right?
So we want to engage the account
teams, we wanna make sure
that they're prepared to respond
and check in with customers early.
We also place a heavy
focus on recovery guidance
and best practices wherever possible.
For some events, there's is actions
that customers can take
that can get them out
of pain earlier and we want to provide
that information as soon as we have it.
Additionally, we're gonna use
the data from the case trends,
the customer impact
reports and the sentiment
as an additional data point
to verify that our mitigations
are working as we expect
and that we understand the
customer experience correctly.
In order to provide detailed
and real time updates,
it's super important that we're in contact
with the tech call that
Giorgio was just discussing.
And so we need that real time
update, right, to be able
to send communications
to you, the customers.
And so we have a two-way communication
that's occurring the entire time
where we're providing information
about the customer experience,
so that technical call
and we're getting information back as
to what's happening in real time,
where we're at in mitigation,
recovery efforts, et cetera.
I wanna show you a visual
here of Command Center.
And so Command Center is
our all-in-one support tool
and this is a Command Center notice.
And so we use Command Center
notices to track and centralize
and share information as
it pertains to an event.
In this example, what you
see on the left hand side is
you see some metadata about the incident.
And so this will include
the service or services
that are impacted.
You'll see the start time
and on the bottom left,
you will see the customer contacts
as we have them and we're relating them.
In the middle,
the very bottom here you'll
see the internal summary.
And so this is where we're
keeping that up to date
so that our customer
facing teams have access
to that real time information
as to what's happening.
Additionally, you'll see at the top here
there's a messaging tab,
and that messaging tab
is where communications
that have been sent to
customers are visible
to those account teams as well.
Finally, we have the
sentiments tab here at the top,
and that's where we're tracking
and reporting on customer feedback.
So communication is key
on the support call.
And so it's important to
communicate to the right audience.
There's two different audiences
that are our main stakeholders here
and those are internal stakeholders
and external customers.
And so external customers
get regular updates,
they get regular recommendations,
and we're communicating
to them specificity about
what's impacted, right,
and clarity over time.
In addition, we're providing
live status updates
to our field teams, the
customer facing account teams,
we want to empower them,
ensure that they have
the latest information
and that they're not caught off guard.
But ultimately we also want
to ingest customer inquiries, right?
And so we can respond by creating FAQs
or bolstering the FAQs
that we already have.
So let's take a deep
dive into communication,
the external communication specifically.
So communication is a matter of balance
and we bias towards speed, right?
We want to communicate as soon as we know
that something is occurring,
we want to give that heads up.
Secondarily though, we have accuracy.
So accuracy we define here as, you know,
we wanna target customers
that are actually impacted,
we want the communications to be relevant
and to be actionable.
We also want them to have as
much detail as possible, right?
So effective resources, et cetera.
Finally, we have depth
of our communications.
And so this is where
clarity is incremental
when it comes with time.
Our first communication
often is very generic
in the sense of we're investigating,
you know, increased error
rates and latencies, but it's
because we want to give you
that communication first
and we do bias towards speed,
but over time, we update
those communications
and we provide details
with specificity as to
what exactly is happening,
what we're seeing about it,
what we're gonna be doing
next, any workarounds
that are available, and time
that we think those steps will take.
- Okay, so here,
you see probably what's
the most common quote
from our tech call and
it's the call leader asking
about a rollback.
I want to discuss now a bunch of measures
that we take for mitigation.
Remember when we started
the event management process
and when we set the incident response,
our one focus is mitigating
the impact for our customers.
We want the service to
recover as soon as possible,
sometimes through side measures.
And without tackling the real root cause,
we want our customers to go
back to their normal operations
so we gain some time for
a deeper investigation.
Now what's probably our most common type
of response is shifting
away from the failure.
Now this is about removing the component
that is failing when we can identify it.
And this goes from simple things
like imagine a large fleet
of instances where we
identify that only a bunch
of them are responding
with increased latency
and we have an uncheck
that automatically takes
them out of the fleet.
Those instances remain broken,
so we are not really
resolving the root cause,
but for the customer,
impact just goes away,
your customers recover
and you get some more time
to conduct a deeper investigation.
Or also more complex cases we
might be investigating again
an increase latency and service
and our metrics showed that
that increase in latency is happening only
in a specific availability zone.
So the first measure here,
remove that availability
zone from service,
let traffic hit only the remaining two
and allow customers to recover.
Once they're recovered you have more time
and just under last way
less pressure to resolve.
Similarly rollbacks.
So when we start the instant management,
the first thing we look at
is if there is any deployment
that is ongoing
or that started at around the
time the event itself started,
we do not only look at the
company that is affected
with some type book at all of AWS.
And again here, if we
suspect some correlation,
we don't waste time to
confirm that correlation.
We just bring everything back
to the previous non unstable state
to mitigate again as soon as we can.
And third, we are in the cloud
and there is a large category of events
that result in increased resource usage.
So because of your increased latency
you might be increased CPU usage.
While you work to
understand what that type
of request is using today
more CPU power than it
was using yesterday,
you can just scale the fleet up
and provide more resources
so that the latency goes back to normal,
and at that point you can investigate.
And then there are a couple
of measures that are part
of the toolkit, we generally
prefer not to take them.
The first one is the turn it off
and done again kind of thing.
So software carries
state, there are caches,
there are buffers and sometimes
restarting a component
can help with recovery.
It's quite a tricky
kind of measure to take
because sometimes with the
restart you're also gonna lose
the state if there are conditions.
So whenever we have to do this, we try
to isolate some nodes on
the side that we can use
for the investigation and
we restart everything else.
And finally, changes are challenging,
especially when non completely tested.
But some events are clearly solved
by a small change in configuration
or by rolling out a new software version
that we were testing to improve
that specific component.
When it's really our last
option, that's what we will do,
and if we have extreme confidence that
that change in configuration
is gonna help the problem,
if we have extreme confidence
that there is a new software
version that is stable,
can be trusted and solves the
issue, we will roll forward.
So once you have mitigated
the issue there is
the deeper resolution phase
and one of the first questions
you ask is about the risk
of recurrence, right?
So before disengaging, there
are a few things that we want
to do and the first one is we,
Anthony mentioned multiple times
how we also use data
coming from our customers
to detect events,
and we use data coming from our customers
throughout the event process
to improve our communication
and overall to make sure
that our internal metrics are
telling us the right story.
We do exactly the same with mitigation.
Once we are confident that we
have mitigated (indistinct),
our metrics are back in the clear,
we just spend that additional
5 minutes, 10 minutes
to confirm with some customers
that they are seeing the same.
Hopefully they will, but if
they want, you can just go back
to incident management mode.
Second one is the risk of recurrence.
So if you made a small
configuration change
or you changed something at runtime,
there might be a pipeline,
a recurring process
or a scheduled change
that is gonna undo it.
You want to put that
whatever temporary patch
you have implemented, it's there to stay.
And additionally, we do it at AWS,
but I guess everyone asks
us the two components,
software components,
SDKs library are reused across services.
So if we suspect a specific library
or a specific piece of code
with a culprit, we want
to go check other services
that are using the same
and we want to validate that
they are not just on the brink
of facing that same issue as well.
And finally, this is the point
where we start forming
root cause hypothesis.
So they don't have to be detailed,
something that you do in 15, 20 minutes,
but we want to have an
idea on what services are
where we want to conduct a deeper dive
in the following hours today.
So ready to close the instant bridge,
the attack call in the case
of AWS, just a small list
of things that we always make sure we do
before closing it.
So we obviously want to validate
that all of the short term fixes critical
to preventing recurrence are complete.
We do not consider the incident result
until we have this done and validated.
And second, we talked
about the tech tickets
and we make sure that
we are preserving all
of the data and logs
that we might need later.
And this ranges from logs
that might be flushed out
in systems every 24 hours
to screenshots that leave
in the laptop of a developer
that was involved in
the incidental solution.
Here is where we check that everything
that we might need later
is stored essentially
forever in the tech ticket.
This is also when we start
assigning the post-mortems.
So every team where we see an opportunity
for improvement, maybe we page the team
and they're on the call,
join five minutes late
or there was another team
that wasn't really sure
on their automation to remove traffic
from an availability zone,
you will have large amount
of engineers taking notes
and all of this stuff during
the event resolution phase,
and at the end we just come together
and assign those post-mortems
to everyone that was involved
and where we see
opportunities for improvement.
It's not a blaming
process, this is just where
we look at how we responded,
we start being self-critical
and just ask teams to deeper investigate
if they could have done anything better.
And finally, well quite obvious,
but we want to make sure that
there is common understanding
of what are the next steps.
We are gonna move out of
the 24/7 operation mode,
we are gonna disengage from the incident,
if someone was paged
overnight, go back to bed.,
but there are two
or three days where work
is still gonna be intense.
We want to make sure that
there is coordination
and a plan for what everyone needs to do.
- Okay, let's take a look
at phase two, reflecting and planning.
So after an incident,
there's gonna be an author
or someone responsible for deep diving
and performing that
post-incident analysis, right?
And it's critical to ensure
that you're examining it
through an effective lens.
So how can you do that?
Well first and foremost, you
need to create a safe space
so that you can understand
the context of decisions
that were made both before,
when the software was designed,
during an incident, but
also after the incident,
in hindsight.
Also assume that decisions were made
with the best intent, right?
Everyone's doing their best
and again, you want it to be a safe space
so that folks feel
comfortable challenging,
they feel comfortable
criticizing, but constructively.
Sometimes it's also important
to do multiple retrospectives.
So don't assume that one
can cover it all, right?
It's important to deep dive any lesson
or any failure that you want
to prevent recurrence of.
And so it's not uncommon for
that to happen with us, right?
If there's a multi-service event
and there's different
learnings that we want
to take away from different teams
and share broadly, we'll do so,
and each team will be responsible
for kind of deep diving
that every failure, everything
that we want to prevent recurrence of.
Okay, so at AWS we call them COEs,
that stands for correction of errors
and this is our post-incident
analysis mechanism
that we have.
So what is a COE?
So A COE is an impact summary
and that's what it starts with.
And it goes over specifically
the timeline of the incident,
what exactly was the customer experience?
It should stand on its own,
be multiple paragraphs
generally in a narrative format,
and again, talk about
the customer experience
and the lifecycle of the event.
It should hit on all the key
milestones of an incident.
It also goes into the root causes.
We do that through the five why's, right?
And the five why's allow
you to really deep dive
and get to the true root cause
and we'll go over that in a
little bit more detail shortly.
But it's super critical
that you're actually getting
to the true root causes in order to ensure
that you're taking the right lessons
and implementing the right actions.
So what comes next are
those learnings, right?
These are the lessons they
should directly come from
and flow from those five
why's and those root causes.
From those lessons, each
of them will generally have
an action item, right?
The lessons are usually things
that we didn't know beforehand
that we want to ensure
that we're capturing for posterity
and taking actions to either educate
or resolve their technical issue.
- So there are a couple of
things we are really big on
when doing COEs and
the first one is we try
to be extremely self-critical
about detection.
We just ask ourselves whether we detected
the event fast enough
and we are happy with our response time.
The chance is that the answer
to this question is no.
Until detection gets
really sort of immediate
and you have an automated mitigation,
there is always gonna be an
opportunity for improvement.
So if the answer is no
and we believe that
there are opportunities
for detecting faster, we
will create action items
for this just as we do for the root cause
of the event itself.
Additionally, now we mentioned a few times
how we use our internal metrics,
we use customers to confirm
that those metrics are
telling us the right story,
but we also want to validate this.
We want to make sure that
throughout the event, we have
the right observability.
So we want to validate
that our metrics were
giving us the real status
and that we're reflective
of the customer experience.
And finally, this is when we
started zooming out a bit.
So we do not focus on
this very specific event,
this other condition,
but look a bit broadly
and try to figure out if we
are confident with our ability
of detecting similar event patterns
and similar incidents in the future.
The second part where we
are big on is dependencies.
Now whether them being
either internal or external,
so using a piece of
software from another team
or from a third party,
dependencies are really useful
as they help avoiding repeated work.
You might just use a component
built by someone else
and focus on what's the core
of your software component.
When an event is caused by a dependence,
it might be really tempting
to just target as such
and completely disengage from
the post incident review.
We do not really allow our teams to do so
and we want them to still
analyze what happened.
The first question, probably
the most obvious is we validate
that the dependency worked as promised.
So every dependency is gonna come
with either an availability
problems or RPO or RTO,
or those sort of metrics,
we want to make sure
that they delivered on
what was sold it was,
internally sold.
The second one is validating
the implementation.
So dependency is not the world story.
How you implement it in
your software might affect
whether an out on that dependence
impacts customers or not.
Then we look at the failure mode
and check if it's something
we should have expected,
something we should have
planned for and didn't
or whether it's something completely new
that there was no way to plan for
and we need to shift to
immediate contingency.
And overall we use those three questions
to find opportunities for
reducing the blast radius.
Now some dependence are just not critical
and think about a webpage that is created
through involving multiple
components in the PIs.
You might just gracefully
degrade the page experience
and not load the component from
that dependence in case
it's not available.
It is, a degraded
experience as the word say,
but it's gonna be much better
that timing out on the entire page
or similarly, you might
be able to cache results.
So be able to still serve a requests
that you have already previous researched.
And again, it's not gonna
be 100% availability
but it's certainly better
than 0% availability.
Okay, that's the wrong section.
So Henry mentioned the five whys
and the five whys are a
really appealing topic
and I think they are one
of the most misunderstood
concepts in the industry.
So they are often explained
as a sequence of questions
where you identify one root cause
and then you ask yourself
what caused the root cause
and then what caused the
second layer and so on.
And the first thing is you
shouldn't really stop at five,
five is a number to give an
idea that is more than two
and less than 100.
But you should really keep
going until you find something
that is meaningful,
until you find a measure
and opportunity for
improvement that if taken helps
with a large range of root causes.
And the second one, the way
they are often explained is
as a chain, and this is
really not the best way
to think about this,
looking at them as a tree
and acknowledging that
events are rarely caused
by a single root, caused
by a single trigger,
but they are often a contribution
of multiple factors is key.
So to make this more tangible,
let's look at an example.
So we started from the issue
that these API calls are failing,
probably most common failure
or some API third party
internal was erroring out.
And we track down those errors
to one host in the fleet
that was returning 500 errors.
So we ask the next why,
it's why was disaster turning 500 errors
and we find some IO
issue errors in its logs
and then we look into those IO errors
and find a problem with
the underlying BS volume.
We look at the underlying BS volume
and find a problem with a
portion of an availability zone.
Now this is really effective,
you are going really deep
and I found fourth layer root cause
that explains the land
but it's only covering one
of the various potential root causes.
So let's look at a better option.
We start with the same question
but not one thing and this is
gonna become apparent soon,
we added some data.
So now we are specifically
talking about 3%
of API errors over a time of 45 minutes.
The first question, the first answer
is the same than before.
So we have one asked out of 100
that is a return $500 errors
and we go down the same branch of before.
It is gonna point out to
a temporary BS failure
in the availability zone.
In parallel to we go
look at our health checks
because reality is that if
health checks were working
and remove that failing
cost from the fleet,
our service would have
kept working regardless
of the underlying disruption
to the storage layer
and figure out that there was a bug, a gap
in our service templates that
was incorrectly implementing
the health check.
Then find the problem
with those 45 minutes, right?
45 minutes of impact due
to single loss failure
are quite significant.
Start looking into that
and we find out that the
engineer was not engaged
for the first 30.
And again, this is an
immediately visible opportunity
for improving the detection time, right?
If this detection was 15 minutes,
then that error would've been 20 minutes
even without changing
anything on the resolution.
And finally I was talking
about numbers, I dunno how many
of you picked it up, but we
are saying that a 1% loss
of capacity because the 3% error rate
and there is created disconnection there.
We go look into that and find a problem
with the load balancing algorithm.
Now, this connection is quite
a painful algorithm to use
because when services are running out,
errors are generally third
faster than actual responses.
So a single failing node attracts
more traffic than it does
when it's effectively working.
And you see how by doing
this, we have not arrived
to a single action that in the
previous cases basically wait
for AWS to solve the AWS problem,
but for nearly completely
independent root causes
and tackling one, two or
three of them is gonna build
the layered resilience towards
that failure condition.
So to a couple of these, when
you think about the five whys,
do not imagine a chain but
rather think about a tree.
It is gonna bring a
range of different issues
and does a range of
different preventive actions.
So when we are done with
this and with internal part,
we start looking at the customer
facing root cause analysis.
And not go too deep into this one,
but one thing we try to do
and we recommend everyone does is
when you write a root cause
analysis for your customers,
start from their point of view
and not from your internal components.
So we try to open a root cause analysis
by explaining the impact to customers,
and you know, when we need to
go deeper into the sequence
of events, we try to
focus on the functions
that customers are familiar with
and not with our internal services
that provide those functions.
And this is overall
about removing unnecessary
complexity, right?
Spending one pager to
describe an internal service,
but the only relevant thing
you have to say is that 20%
of (indistinct) in that
service were misbehaving
and were not detected, we
just gonna drift the attention
and not be productive.
While writing the root cause analysis,
there is a really important
balance to take that is
between quality and speed.
Anthony mentioned that how
in event communications,
speed is our primary metric.
We want to be out with a notification
that something is wrong as soon as we can,
and through iteration we are gonna explain
what that something is.
We're gonna share data us on
the service, on the region,
on the type of failure.
Now our SCAs are a document
that is delivered once.
So we do not get this
opportunity to iterate,
but we're also aware that our
customers are waiting for it.
They are waiting for our RCAs
to understand what happened,
but more importantly to read
what we are doing about it
and by when we are
planning to do such things.
One thing that might be
not immediately visible is
that RCAs are not only a way
to explain a technical failure,
but they're also a way
to regain the trust of your customers.
So if you're writing, one,
it's because you failed
and customers are gonna inspect you,
they're gonna inspect your response,
they're gonna inspect your long-term plans
and they're gonna use
that to decide whether
to keep using your service or not.
So I think RCAs as an opportunity
to earn customer trust
or to regain their confidence is quite key
to delivering high quality documents.
Okay, so after this part is done
and we have an eye level
prompt to customers,
we start looking into the
detail of our action items.
Now we categorize action items
based on how long it takes
to plan them and how stable they are.
The first type that really
doesn't happen at this stage,
the first type is the short
term ones that we discussed
in terms of things that happen
before we close the incident bridge.
So they happen in hours, we work 24/7
until they are implemented,
and they are focused on preventing
the immediate recurrence.
Now, short term action items are effective
but might not be particularly sustainable.
Like you can imagine this
as starting a software
component once a day
to clear the buffers and caches
or to overengaging engineers
every time a matrix starts
spiking in the wrong direction.
It's fine to keep them
for a few days, it's not
fine to keep them forever.
The second category is the midterm ones.
This is when you start building
a self-sustaining solution
that allows your teams
to go back to the priorities
they were working on
before that.
They're generally
implemented in days to weeks,
more rarely months, and
those tend to be the promise
that we put in the customer-facing
root cause analysis.
Then we have a third type
that is really long term action items.
And this is when we think
about systemic change
or when we start reinventing.
And this type of actions may be building
a completely new service
that solves a problem better
than the previous version,
or that solves a problem
that no service is solving.
This is a real quote, quite fun
because shows how while building
this action item tion not just focus
on incremental improvement,
and once again it's a matter
of trade offs and balances.
There are four forces
that are really relevant when
looking at long-term plans
and preventive actions.
So the first one is the trade off
between incremental
change versus innovation.
So incremental change, you
can see it as something
that is rolled out slowly,
that is always retro compatible
and doesn't require any
action from the customers,
from the user of API or from
downstream dependencies.
It's easy to implement
but it's slow and easy
to use for the end customers.
Innovation is building new solutions.
New solutions are categorized two things.
So the first one is they are new,
so it's gonna be a new service customers
are gonna have to move to.
And this doesn't really
discount from fixing
the previous version because
there is gonna be a ramp up
down from the old one and
the ramp up to the new one
that is gonna take quite a
significant amount of time.
And then they might be
completely incompatible.
Might be a new service that behaves
in a completely different way
that doesn't have the full
functionality that the previous one.
And the second one is related to timing.
So after an event, it's really
common to start focusing
on what seemed to be perfect solutions.
So you're gonna completely
rebuild a component
or you're gonna deprecate an
API or stop doing something.
The problem is it's really key
to have realistic completion dates.
When internal and external
customers have been impacted
by a failure on a dependency,
they are gonna expect
some significant actions
and some significant prevention happening
in weeks to months maximum.
So here is when you take a decision
between promising a perfect
solution maybe two years out
that doesn't really solve
the immediate problem,
or promising something in the middle
that you can deliver quicker,
and after you have done that,
then you can go (indistinct) mode.
Okay, so at this stage
you have your action items defined,
promise to the customers and
you have internal resourcing
and planning to carry them on.
It's really common since
all of this phase happened
in days after the event.
The RCA needs to be out
in seven days maximum,
and by that point you're making a promise.
And then you go into
an implementation phase
that might last 3, 4, 5 weeks.
And as you do that,
you might find better opportunities.
So you might decide that
the plan you promise
to your customers is not really the best.
We are generally fine
with changing those plans
as long as we don't change
the goal and the promise.
So if you have a
different way to implement
a similar solution that prevents
the same failure condition,
we will do that.
While doing this, it's
extremely important to stick
to the estimated completion dates
that you have promised to your customers.
Now they are really not set in stone,
it's fine to push them out by one
or two days if you need them, if you need
to validate a solution,
but it's important to not
push them out by month.
So I was trying to come up with a number
before this talk to say like
being 20% slower is fine,
being 2000% slower is maybe
not, I didn't find this number,
but I have the feeling
it's gonna be quite low.
And finally, this is
drilled into our mindset,
but preventive action is not completed
the moment implemented,
it's completed the moment you test it
and validated the same
underlying conditions do not
lead to the same failure.
Again, this is key in communication,
but those in terms of thinking,
the job doesn't stop at implementation,
stops after you are confirmed
that what's implemented was
right and works at scale.
- Okay, let's look at phase three.
So phase three is learning and scaling.
So the most important
COEs get to phase three.
Here's a quote here and
it's worth acknowledging
that as privileged male technical folks,
Malcolm X was probably not thinking
of us when writing these words,
but their words are
inspirational nonetheless, right?
And so it's super important
to take every opportunity
to learn a lesson
and improve your
performance the next time.
And it's the mental model
that we have here at AWS
and it's part of our
operational excellence
and it's critical in the
process here for COEs.
Okay, so let's look at learning.
So there's a couple
different phases of learning.
So we review all COEs within a team.
Every service or author that writes a COE,
they're gonna review that
with their individual team.
Additionally, they'll review that
with their wider organization,
but we also have the AWS
operational metrics meetings.
And so these are meetings
that occur on Wednesdays
and everyone is involved,
everyone is invited
in all of AWS.
That includes product managers,
that includes engineers,
from leaders, everyone.
And it's super important that
they're all engaged as well.
And this is part of our
culture that allows us
to scale these lessons across
not only one organization
or one team, but all of AWS.
And so it's super important,
it's a critical mechanism
to ensure that these are learned once
and not multiple times.
The other key here is
looking for patterns, right?
And looking for patterns and ensuring
that you're leveraging solutions
across the organization.
Again, a safe space is
super important, right,
and so there's some ground rules there.
Open discussion is absolutely welcome,
but everyone should feel
comfortable speaking up,
everyone should feel comfortable
challenging action items,
asking whether they're the right things,
you know, and challenging the five why's
and how we got to the
solutions that we did.
You'd be surprised, but for
a meeting with thousands
of folks, it is incredible amount
of value that we get out of that meeting.
Okay, so let's look at
the scaling aspect of it.
So I kind of alluded to it there,
but scaling goes through
three phases, right?
So the first one is team education.
And so in order of increased
effectiveness, right?
So the first one is education.
They're the best intention,
it's not necessarily mechanistic
and they don't necessarily scale
to other teams and other organizations.
Then you have a distributed change,
and a distributed change is one
where everyone has to go do something.
And so it can be expensive
but ultimately it can scale.
And then finally we have
a centralized change.
And so a centralized
change is where you go
and you make a centralized change,
and so everyone gets
that by default, right?
They consume that, these are changes
to the SDKs, default behaviors, et cetera.
So one example of a team education is
not only just reviewing
the COEs within your team
and within your organization, but tenets.
And so tenets are our core
foundational principles
that we use to help guide us.
And so here's an example of
some of our operational tenets.
I'm not gonna talk about all of them,
but the first one obviously,
failures must not impact
multiple regions is certainly
a lesson that everyone at
AWS is very well aware of.
And additionally, there's
detecting failures
before your customers do.
And so this is an obvious one where
in that operational metrics
meeting, if we determine
that customers were the root cause
or the catalyst rather
of identifying an issue,
it's a easy COE to write in
the sense that it was a failure
and we have to go figure out why.
There's improvements to monitoring,
there's improvements to metrics
and alarming that we need to go take.
And so for an example
of distributed change,
distributed change here
is trusted advisor.
And so trusted advisor is
a service that we built
to scale our learnings
directly with customers, right?
And so it monitors your infrastructure,
categorize recommendations
based on severity.
On the left here you can see an example
of four critical recommendations.
I think Giorgio,
you might have a couple
unread notifications here
in the AWS Health console
on the top right there.
Well, they're not only
categorized by priority
but they're also related to performance,
cost optimization, et cetera.
The key here is that we have
identified lessons, right,
and we wanna scale those
lessons to customers
and that's the distributed
change model here.
But ultimately customers
have to prioritize them.
And so it's not necessarily
the most effective
but it's certainly well worth doing.
- Thank you.
Just to clarify, that's
a non-production account.
I was looking for example
of bad trusted advisor pages
and so i had to go dig in an
account that I rarely use.
So the third type, the centralized change
and invention that we have
mentioned multiple times.
Now you might not know that,
but most of the services you
use today in AWS are coming
from our experience of
a world without them
and they are solutions we
build to actual problems
we were facing.
A really common one in case
you were managing DNS 15 years ago
or fun fact, Route 53 is
turning 15 in like three days.
You knew how hard it was not
only for building scalable
and resilient data plane
but also for managing control
at an organizational scale.
So building the right policies
for only the right individuals being able
to modify a certain DNS ad so on
or some records was just not easy,
and that's why we built Amazon Route 53.
Similarly, load balancers
used to be physical,
they used to be physical
appliances that you were packing,
that you were managing and
updating, quite painful overall.
And that's one of the reasons
why we built a Elastic Load Balancer.
We built it for us in the first place
and to solve a problem we were having,
we wanted a really scalable
virtual load balancer
that could be provisioned on demand.
We just wanted to stop,
we link in servers every time we needed
to launch a new server service
and that's how it came to be.
And similarly, I dunno,
but if you were to manage
a certificate rotation
in a large organization,
you're not doing this through
spreadsheets and meetings,
it's not the best possible idea,
and AWS certificate managers
today makes it so simple,
you basically forget about certificates
and you can also afford
to rotate them way more often
than we were used to before.
There is a little bit of
a case study that I want
to show on all of those
things come together
and also a case study
and now we sometimes get the timing wrong,
but you should have heard about Identity
and Access Management, AWS IAM.
So it's a globally consistent service
that you use in the build phase
or while deploying a service
to define permission, success policies,
and define what users and roles can do.
Next IAM there is a security
token service, AKA AWS STS.
So the service is regional
instead, it's stateless,
and at runtime to generate
temporary credentials
that then are used to connect
and make requests with AWS services.
Now this services is sort
of in the critical path
because it's not in the
middle of every request,
but temporary credentials
are really short lived.
So you need this SDS to
be extremely resilient.
As many things, SDS was at the beginning
all in a single region.
So when we started
launching multiple regions
across the globe,
for a few years, it would've
had to make a request
to US-east-1, get credentials
and then be allowed to use
services in the regions field.
By 2015, we figured out this was a problem
and launched the regional SDS assistance.
This allowed customers to
isolate their workloads
and make sure that a
failure in an region was
not spreading to others.
This also when we changed
the best practice,
so this is when we start
talking about team education.
We immediately documented the fact
that using regional was better
and a more resilient option,
but left it pretty much it there.
And by 2022 we figured out
that traffic was still
significant on the legacy endpoint
and that there was quite a
significant availability risk
for our customers.
So we changed the defaults
and we started with active campaigns
for customers to move off.
So this is when you get a
personal dashboard notification
that asked to stop using a certain thing
or implement a change by a date.
Unfortunately by 2024, traffic
on the global endpoint was
still really substantial,
and this is when we figured out
that giving the right guidance
or the distributed kind of
change were not effective
and we are to take a
measure that will allow us
to solve this quickly and for everyone
and without customer action.
And that's why in April this
year we implemented a change
that essentially naming
here gets really confusing
because the global endpoint is now served
for regions enabled by
default by the region itself.
So customers don't change anything,
use the same endpoint than before,
but the request instead
of getting to US-east-1,
gets to the same region and
removes this dependency.
And to give you an idea
on how this worked.
So here we have a graph,
it goes from early February
to mid April, it's normalized,
the 100% on the Y is
the starting point where we
consider the starting point 100%
of affected accounts.
And this out traffic changes
on the global endpoint
as we roll out the change.
So this shows a deployment
that starts slowly
and tests just to make
sure we are deploying
the right thing.
And then towards the end
you'll see the deployment going
at increasing speed and hitting regions,
and traffic cross region traffic
near drops to nearly zero.
- Okay, so there's a couple
of takeaways that we want you
to remember leaving this talk.
So first and foremost,
engage early, engage often,
ensure that leaders are
engaged, everyone wants
to be involved and they
should welcome engagement
and make sure that you
have the right folks
at the right time.
- The second one is focus
on fast communications
during event.
Make sure you send out a notification
that tells your customers
that something is potentially going wrong
and think about iterating on depth later.
- Mitigate first and root cause later.
So we're all engineers,
we want to deep dive
and figure out what the
root cause is, right?
But during an incident is not the time
to figure out the root cause,
mitigate customer impact
and root cause has its time
and its place afterwards.
- Finally, incidents are
really powerful lessons.
The problem is that they
are extremely expensive
and come with customer impact.
You want to make sure that you learn once
as an organization.
So don't limit the learnings
to the team that was affected
or the team that was the
cause of the incident,
but make sure that whatever
they learn, spread across all
of the engineers in the team.
- And then ensure that when
you reflect, you reflect
with empathy, you create a safe space
where folks are welcome to ask questions
and feel confident in doing so.
- And finally, whenever you
need a really simple set
of rules that are easy to
remember, that are easy to teach
to new (indistinct) and that can be used
as a tiebreaker when there
is our decisions to take,
just define tenets.
You have seen ours,
something similar can be done
and tenets are supposed to
be really short sentences
that withstand the test of time
and can help driving decisions.
You will find them extremely
useful when two teams
that maybe are not closely
working together need
to collaborate to launch a service,
that set of five tenets,
ten tenets is gonna help them
just building a shared roadmap
and shared outcomes that are
relevant for the company.
- Alright, well Giorgio and
I both wanna thank you all
for coming. Feel free to
take a picture of this slide.
We'll be available outside the room
after the presentation here.
We're obviously passionate
about this topic
and so we're happy to discuss.
Please complete this session in the,
sorry, the session
survey in the mobile app.
We'd love your feedback and
we want to improve next time.